on your own so the beginning of this
research area we started to understand
the distribution of the skin microbiota
in adults so this was work done by
Elizabeth Grace and part of the human
microbiome project many years ago and
essentially what they found was on an
adult and what I mean by adult year is
sort of a 30 to 40 year old or somewhere
between 20 and 40. so a middle-aged or
younger aged adult after puberty puberty
what they looked at here was in the
sebaceous area of the body so as I
mentioned the face the upper trunk the
upper you know back and chest area we
have more of the compounds that are
sebaceous so we have more sebaceous
glands and so we have more sebum and
sebum is you know essentially oil when
you when you talk about it in a lay term
you have more of it there and as a
result of that you tend to have more
organisms that metabolize that compound
and that happens to be cutie bacteria
they used to be called propione
bacterium we changed the name because
you know in understanding their
uh where their origin and their
phylogeny we actually start to
understand they're not propionary
bacteria anymore they're called cutie
bacterium so that's important to
understand but this is driving so the
environment on the skin is driving these
organisms and like I said same with the
moist areas like under you know the
axilla in between or under your arm or
between your your elbow crease on your
feet Etc these are going to drive a very
different kind of microbiome and so you
can see a lot of
staphylococcus and carotene bacteria
present in those various areas and then
in dry areas like your lower leg or your
forearm or your hand you see a lot more
proteobacteria
other kinds of organisms that are
present there you see staphylococci so
you know in atopic dermatitis for
example a lot of people have flares of
that skin issue eczema again in the
elbow crease or behind the knee and that
happens to be driven largely by this
organism called staphylococcus aureus
and they're they live in that
environment naturally so part of why a
disease manifests in a certain part of
your body is because in a state of
balance they live there happily not
causing you a problem but when there's
an issue like with acne there's
overproduction of sebum or an
inflammatory response to those bacteria
or in the case of atopic dermatitis you
know a barrier disruption your skin
breaks down the organisms are already
there and they can take advantage of
that situation so it's important to
understand on that as you explore the
skin microbiome
so this is some work that that we did at
Johnson and Johnson early on when again
we started seeing this work on the adult
microbiome and we had you know an
interest in understanding infant and how
infant skin evolves over time it's area
of research that we've done there for
many years and so this was a study that
we did to look at what does the
microbiome look like in the first year
of life in infants so we took a cohort
of infants aged you know I think three
weeks or two a month all the way to 12
months of age so these are different
infants in a series of groups so there
are about 12 or 15 babies in each of
these age groups so aged one to three
months four to six months and seven to
twelve months and we looked at what does
their microbiome look like is it like in
adults does it look different we know
that the structure and the function of
the skin in infants is different they
don't produce that much sebum because
that happens at puberty when your
hormones change and start dictating
changes in your in your biology like
sebum production that's why acne is more
predominant or starts to be more
predominant at that point in your life
but what we saw was that in an infant
microbiome it does not look like an
adult you don't see this is basically
the class of bacteria that QD bacterium
are a part of which are the acne causing
ones the ones you see all over your face
and and your upper trunk those are a
very large part of our microbiome in an
adult and that's because of the sampling
in this area in other parts of the area
you don't see as many of them as you saw
on the previous slide but on average
this is what you see but in an infant
you see very different result you see
much more of these what we call
firmicutes staphylococci streptococci on
their skin so immediately it's clear
that the microbiome is not the same
across time so there's something
different going on as the skin changes
over over your lifetime and what we can
see here is an increase in diversity
that's occurring over time and this
would make sense in the sense that when
a baby is born it's their first exposure
to microorganisms you know largely uh
outside of the womb and so their skin is
essentially now getting colonized with
organisms through the hospital
environment Mom and Dad other people
touching and holding the baby all of
those microbes that we have on our skin
are getting exposed to the infant skin
and then the infant Skin's environment
and its unique environment is driving
who gets to survive and colonize and
live there and so what we see like I was
mentioning is a lot of strep and staff
and then over time you see this
expansion in these other organisms in
the skin so you're seeing this increase
in diversity over time but it's probably
not done yet by the first year of age so
what we did was then we followed those
same infants over time so for the next
seven years basically we followed them
as well as their mothers to look at how
the microbiome continued to evolve in a
in a child over time
so this would be for example in year one
would be the samples of infants I just
showed you on the previous slide this is
what their standard diversity would look
like so how diverse is their microbiome
it would be this is the starting point
by two to three years we don't see a
significant change over time yet and our
hypothesis is there is because the skin
isn't that different yet they're
starting to they're still at home
they're still in their you know local
environment the skin isn't you know
actively changing they're not growing
that different from you know very early
in their lives but by five and six years
of age maybe they're going to school now
maybe they're exposed to a different
environment and their skin structure
function starts to evolve and so you
start to see this increase in diversity
and yet again by six to seven years old
increase again and this is in contrast
to their mothers who microbiome while
variable is largely consistent
and so this is in you know again in that
younger age range you know of an adult
the microbiome is pretty stable and so
we we've known this for a while I think
there was a study done over the course
of two years which demonstrated that in
adults the microbiome
um of the skin doesn't change so it
becomes like your microbial fingerprint
but there were continued questions about
well is that forever I mean as we
continue to age our skin changes yet
again we get into you know for example
here once this likely continues to
evolve until we hit puberty the hormones
are then really driving a lot of changes
in the skin that's when you get your
quote adult-like microbiome all those
cutie bacteria that colonize the skin
and that's when your microbiome becomes
very stable but then you continue to age
and we know as we age our skin changes
the structure changes the function
changes
so what does the microbiome look like
there so I'll get into that in a second
but this is just a summary of what I was
just describing this idea of the
microbiome continuing to evolve and then
it says in the young adult State It's
relatively stable with the organisms
present
but now we know that as we continue to
age because we all do and we get into
our 50s 60s and 70s the microbiome
changes yet again and so this was a
study done by Procter Gamble it was
published just this year
that looked at an adult but all of these
were female subjects so they looked at
the buttock skin the face skin and the
forearm skin of all of these 100 and
some odd women that they recruited into
their study and what they see is that
there are a large number of lactivacilli
that they see present on the buttock
skin that go down over time now this is
largely because in the vaginal
microbiome we often have lactobacilli
especially in young age because it's
driven or it's dictated largely by
estrogen production and as our estrogen
production goes down in older age
lactobacilli don't have their favorite
food sources anymore which is driven by
estrogen and so the vaginal microbiome
becomes less lactobacillus dominant and
the buttock skin is quite close to the
environment so this is very likely why
we see reductions of lactobacillus as we
age on that part of the body it's not
because necessarily they colonize and
live on the buttock skin although
there's more work I think that would
need to be done to understand that but
importantly on the surface of the facial
skin so as we've been discussing this
cutie bacterium level is going down as
we continue to age so you see a lot of
them here and this is what you saw on
that younger adult age range 30 40 50 or
20 30 40 rather and then as you age that
amount of bacteria goes down and that's
because as we age our skin doesn't
produce as much sebum anymore it dries
out it wrinkles it changes in structure
and so these organisms that love oil
don't have their favorite food source
anymore and other organisms take up that
space instead so some of the interesting
questions are do does that shift in the
microorganisms then contribute to the
aging process or is it simply an
artifact of the changing of the skin I
mean we've evolved with these organisms
so I think there are a lot of
interesting questions that have yet to
be answered about that
and this is an example from that same
study of the diversity changes that you
see so you're seeing essentially an
increase in diversity over time and this
is important because at the beginning of
this field it was diversity is key we
always want to have more diversity but
that's not always the case it depends on
what you're looking at what environment
and at what point in time you're looking
at it so as you see here because you are
aging in the face is the the easiest way
to look at this as the as you age you
know you have propionary bacteria cutie
bacterium driving a very dominant part
of that microbiome so you have low
diversity because they're taking up most
of the space so you don't have a lot of
these other organisms but as you age and
the sebum goes away all of these other
organisms take up that space so you see
an expansion in diversity is that a good
thing or a bad thing I don't think we
know the answer to that and what the
impact of that change is on the micro or
on the skin rather itself and this is an
example of the sebaceous gland changes
that are occurring so the sebaceous
gland function is larger in early life
and goes down over time so it's
correlating with these changes in
diversity
so this is a graph I made to sort of
depict if you will the change in
microbial diversity over our lifetime to
summarize what I just showed you and
that is here what you see you know in a
newborn microbial diversity infancy
childhood is increasing we reach
adolescence where you see lots of oil
production and the Cutie bacteria taking
over and then in a younger adulthood
becomes very stable you have healthy
barrier function and this is all in
healthy skin for example and that's
pretty much the way it stays for a while
until you start Aging in advanced stage
you know as you get into your 50s 60s
70s now the sebum production goes down
your barrier changes and diversity goes
up again and where it goes from there
will continue to study this but this
gives you a depiction of the changes
that are occurring over time